[Applause]
yeah nice what's up guys we're pumpkin
aunty
today we're doing a special episode with
one of our subscribers
he's stefanos and he's from Greece
welcome thank you guys it's nice to be
here
I'm a big fan of your channel so I hope
you have a great time today I'm sure
[Music]
okay stefanos first trick shot around
the net and hit the cup there stefanos
is going to show us how Greek people do
be around the net
oh he has it easy easy easy for Stefan
yeah ok let's try with the backhand side
bullseye finally ok so that went pretty
well with you around yeah yeah good next
one is a serve around the cups and the
ball has to line inside the bin
that should be different
yeah that's that's a bit more spinner
than that's it
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
now he goes yeah there we go
yeah oh really good really good
how long have you been subscribed
anything you think one year for sure
yeah I've been following your videos
cool large the time for between the live
show what do you think sounds good let's
go for it
now we have it nice one
[Music]
start with the racket here and then hit
those yeah have it have it here and then
hit it yeah they don't oh yeah
[Music]
Oh
yeah
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
we have to hit all the cops down from
the table let us try ok nice nice ok
stepping on so do you think you play
around the back that will be very easy
yeah that's you
[Music]
I have your body like this and then you
you hit it like this so don't turn your
head because then you lose the ball just
a smaller and more safe
[Music]
that
[Music]
yeah that's pretty good
a friend of mine does this very well
yeah it's a myth that you will be
laughing so Stephanus we've been really
impressed by a trick shots it's been fun
fitness level stuff really not my only
yeah so guys remember to subscribe and
see the previous videos exactly
until next time yeah bye